really excited about our next guest he
is one of hollywood's brightest talents
academy award winner aaron sorkin the
writer and director is best known for
blockbuster films like a few good men
and hit tv shows like the west wing and
the newsroom his highly anticipated new
movie being the ricardo's is a dramatic
look behind the scenes of the cbs show i
love lucy starring lucille ball and desi
arnaz of course lucy and desi are played
by nicole kidman and javier bardem in
this clip lucy admits to registering to
vote as a communist earlier in her life
after being called out during a time of
growing fear about communism watch
i didn't check the wrong box you saw the
headline you could see the headline from
outer space then
fred raised me for when i was age four
he cared about the little guy he cared
about workers rights it was a tribute to
him and to say that i checked
grandpa for a grandpa friend was wrong
lucy
yes he didn't tell you the part where
they throw your father in prison for the
crime of being the mayor of the city
i was chased to this country lucy
believe me you checked the wrong box
first on cbs mornings aaron sorkin joins
us now good morning good morning good to
see you so we were talking about this
movie we loved it thank you i love your
work i told you backstage i love your
work i love nicole kidman's work i love
javier bardem
i'm a huge i love lucy fan when i heard
about your casting decision i was a
little concerned
gotta say like a lot of fans you
probably heard this real vlad right i'm
keeping it real but wow
they embody these characters like
nothing i've ever seen they do um and uh
you were at a disadvantage because uh
i'd read the script and you had it
uh the the role isn't lucy ricardo and
ricky ricardo it's it's lucille ball and
desi arnaz uh and
they are entirely different people from
from lucy and ricky yeah i love an
untold story and not only did you do a
really great job of telling a story but
you got the green light from their
children
so what surprised you about this what
will surprise the audience yeah well
lucy arnaz as he said has been uh
incredibly supportive and during the
period when i was kind of you know i'd
been asked if i wanted to write a movie
about lucille ball and desi arnaz and it
took me about 18 months to to get to a
yes it's a it's a big commitment so it
takes me a while to say yes but during
that period lucy arnez
kind of took me aside and quietly said
to me listen my mother was not an easy
woman take the gloves off
and i thought that that invitation
it was interesting to me now one of the
central story lines is how women
navigated show business at the time even
diving into her being pregnant and not
being able to work talk a little bit
more about that that's right uh
lucy was the most powerful person in
television though she couldn't really
exercise that power uh because as she
says at one point in the film she
navigates male egos for a living uh it
was also
uh this
a
fracture
in her relationship with desi they were
deeply in love with each other
passionately in love with each other uh
but desi
comes from a culture that has a very
narrow definition of manhood and where
manhood is very important
and so as much as he loved lucy as much
as he really admired and respected her
talent
it was difficult for him to be a second
banana to anyone what i really
appreciated was your ability to tell
desi story because he was largely
overlooked in his contribution
not only to his family but to the
business of desi lou
no doubt about it i i think that anyone
in the last 60 years who has done a half
hour comedy on television
walking in the footprints that uh that
desi made
technically and storyline wise
absolutely
desi was the one who
came up with the multi-camera system for
half hour television wow uh which i i
won't bore your viewers with amazing
important nobody's important because it
set the tone for every
television series that followed that's
right they were pioneers and not only
were they pioneers in in television
production i think what you also do
aaron is you really highlight this
incredible love story that they had i i
saw a video that lucille arnaz posted
years ago
of desi and lucy in a pool with their
grandchildren they were long divorced
but they were they had a connection that
lasted even after they they loved each
other until the
for the day they died uh and you know
one of the things about the film
is that it's heartbreaking that these
two can't get it together
uh uh to have that marriage
uh
uh and
they both remarried but interestingly uh
desi
remarried lucy's stand-in
um which is incredible yeah
oh he has a type
what are some of your favorite memories
of i love lucy i mean vlad said it we
are all huge fans of the show it's one
of those shows that just it crossed
generations yes what about for you it
did you know for me uh i i can remember
you know being homesick from school and
in the mornings i think there were four
i love lucy episodes in a row yes uh and
i'd go through them and i like most
people i love the physical comedy so
yeah obviously the chocolate factory and
uh we do
uh
we we show and i just want to be really
clear on this the movie is not i love
lucy yes uh it takes place during one
production week of i love lucy monday
table read to friday audience taping uh
and we see
uh shards of i love lucy throughout
because we're going into lucy's mind we
can see that she's kind of a comedic
chess master uh and you know when
they're at the table read when she's
hearing a pitch in the writers room when
they're rehearsing uh she can see a joke
on the page and visualize what it's
going to be like in front of the
audience on friday whether it's going to
work yeah uh or not um
uh and in in those shards of i love lucy
we see a moment or two of the famous
grape stomping scene yeah
we we love i love lucy because of the
smiles and the laughs this movie pulls
back the curtain yes and dives into
their lives well done it's really thank
you so much for joining thank you very
very much thanks for having me
appreciate you being the ricardo's hits
theaters on december 10th